[Music]
you're seven years old
sitting in a classroom with 50 kids you
don't know
the teacher is talking
about
you see her point at the blackboard
you hear her voice
but you do not understand a word
and you have just a few months
to pass an exam
in this unknown language
that's no nightmare
that was my childhood growing up in
india
moving every few years
from a state where everyone spoke hindi
to a state where everyone spoke bangla
to a state where everyone spoke uriah
at seven
when everything seemed impossible
i wanted to cry
i wanted to run away
i wanted to quit
but i tried my best
to push away my doubts and fears and
power through
at nine when we moved again
it got just a bit easier
even though i could not talk to my
classmates for a while we connected over
cricket and volleyball
we shared delicious parathas over lunch
and we teamed up at scouts after school
by 11
i was almost looking forward to the next
move
the promise of new friends
new rivals
new foods
far outweighed the miscommunication
living this experience as a child was
transformative
over time
i got better and better
at shoving away my doubts and fears and
powering
through eventually the move stopped
but left behind was this strange
tingling openness
to try new things
you've heard the cliches take a leap of
faith
jump into the deep end and learn to swim
fake it till you make it
nobody told me any of that back then
for me it was simple
the discomfort goes away if you just
power through
and power through i did
before coming to the gsb i spent 15
years at a b2b tech company
starting as an engineer in india
and pivoting over 10 times
in those 15 years across roles
functions
teams even geographies
i went out of my way to master new
skills
working during the day
and starting evenings and weekends for
three years to get a business degree to
pivot to marketing
learning spanish for presentations and
deals in mexico
traveling the world meeting customers to
understand
their pain points always at work i would
settle for nothing less than exceeding
expectations
powering through served me quite well
until it didn't
when i got promoted to a manager i put
the same pressure on my team to exceed
expectations that i put on myself
i was sure
they would get through their discomfort
by powering through
so when the first 360 reviews came in i
was excited
i remember running upstairs this corner
conference room with frosted glass walls
to read in private
and i opened my reviews one by one the
first one read
switch it should avoid being so pushy
it was as if those frosted glass walls
shattered around me
i could feel my energy go away who could
be this malcontent
with a little more hope i opened the
second review and it read
such it should trust and empower the
team more and let go of the details
oh no
i could feel the blood drain down my
head as i slouched into my chair
the reviews did not get any better from
there
by the time
i got through them i felt like that
seven-year-old again
i wanted to cry
i want it to run away
i want it to quit
and among those lines one line stayed
with me
such it needs to pause and smell a few
more roses
was i missing something
i realized
not immediately but over the next
several months
that all those doubts and fears i had
shoved away were still out there in the
shadows
powering through
had a cost that i hadn't reckoned with
before
i had moved way too often to form
long-term and deep friendships
i felt this awkward distance with people
that others perceived as me being
disconnected
the idea of home for me was not tied to
a particular place but only
to a close group of people
eventually the 11 year old in me took
over
i powered through once again and i
reached out to a trusted mentor and
coach for help
who convinced me to pause and reflect on
the impact i was having on my team
gradually i learned to embrace the truth
that each member of my team had more
years of experience than i did
i learned
to align each member's individual goals
with that of the team and the
organization
i organized team building exercises
where there were no hierarchies i leaned
in to listen more
to gain consensus to understand their
perspectives
but above everything
i stopped expecting them to power
through every discomfort the way i did
standing here now
i know i talked to an audience of people
who powers through
who shoves away
doubts and fears who takes leap after
leap after leap
and even though it works for you even
though it works for us
we need to remember as we try to change
lives organizations and the world
that not all the people we lead
operate the same way
we need to have empathy and
understanding for the people on our
teams
who may respond to discomfort
differently we cannot push them as hard
as we push ourselves
it is also important to know that how we
act sets an example
for our colleagues
for our employees and as i recently
realized even
for our families
the other day my wife minal and i were
discussing our next steps after
graduation
we lived in atlanta before we got to
stanford should we go back or should we
stay here
so i turned to my almost nine-year-old
son
ryan
what do you think atlanta or california
dad neither
i think i want to try some place new
at that moment i felt overwhelmed inside
so proud of it of his adventurous spirit
much like me when i was nine
yet concerned that he might also
miss a place that felt like home
there is a balance
between always powering through
and pausing to smell the roses
between moving on
and enjoying
where you are and what you have
i wish i could tell you exactly where
that balance lies but i'm still trying
to find it
so my ask of you today is this
keep in mind not only the benefits but
also the costs of always powering
through
and try to find a balance
that works for you and just as
importantly for the people you lead
[Applause]
[Music]